pedra the second leads brazil in sid
meier's civilization 6 his nickname was
the magnanimous and he earned a
reputation as an enlightened monarch he
corresponded with scholars around the
world and pushed for the abolition of
slavery magnanimous is also Pedro's
special ability after recruiting or
patronizing a great person he will
recoup some of the points cost resile
can build a unique district the
Carnivale district replaces the
entertainment complex once constructed
the city can build the carnival city
project turning production into extra
amenities when the project is complete
Brazil gets additional great person
points the meanest gerace is brazil's
unique unit this is unlocked through the
nationalism Civic it has improved
defense and ranged combat values Brazil
also gets additional adjacency bonuses
for building districts adjacent to rain
forests players will have to make some
tough choices about whether to develop
their rain forests or leave them alone
for extra bonuses
you
if you like great people then you're
going to love playing as Brazil plan
well around rainforests and you'll have
cities capable of producing gold culture
and faith which you can use to drive a
steady stream of great people with
Brazil's unique carnevale district
you'll keep your people happy and
continue to recruit great people great
person generation is valuable for every
victory type making Brazil a flexible
sieve whose legacy stands on the
shoulders of giants will you be Brazil's
next great leader how will you achieve
victory in Sid Meier's Civilization six
you